gmh i.t i.t - dia RQ f RM let's get
right to it will you do Sharpie face
yeah I guess but only for the answers
how involved do you plan to be in the
making of the tiffy oast movie I'll be
involved in any way that I can be
helpful but I know that I'm not like a
movie person wait they're making a movie
out of The Fault in Our Stars yes the 90
Woodfox mm option to movie rights to The
Fault in Our Stars so hopefully they
will make it it's too soon to get
excited but keep your fingers crossed my
face is burning well you ever come to
the nether once again yes in fact I'm
going to the Netherlands this week there
will be a nerdfighter gathering in
Amsterdam on Friday night more info in
the doobly-doo have you ever been drunk
I don't know I mean not like really
drunk have you ever been to Mardi Gras
in New Orleans alright yeah I have been
really drunk why don't you ever do
champagne poppers anymore I just started
to feel like I'm a grown man trying to
make video blogs that can be taken
seriously and champagne poppers just
aren't part of that brand what the
nerdfighter kiva group at $500,000
shibam ow wow that was uncomfortable
have you had any experience with drugs
yeah but quite a lot of experience
actually for instance on several
occasions this class of drugs called
antibiotics did an amazing job of
helping me to not be dead do you get
annoyed when people correct your grammar
oh you mean like I just split an
infinitive I only get annoyed when
people use grammar as a way of
humiliating other people in YouTube
comments rather than using grammar for
what it's supposed to be used for which
is to make language as clear and
intelligible as possible what's the
moment when you realized you were old
let me ask you a question if I'm so old
how come my face is covered in sharpie
who do you think should play hazel and
Augustus in a movie of The Fault in Our
Stars I have no idea because of course I
know nothing of contemporary actors and
actresses like in my mind's imagination
drew Barrymore is still 17 years old
more importantly who would you want to
play hazel and Augustus in the movie is
The Fault in Our Stars still on the
bestseller list
yes it's currently number 2 on New York
Times bestseller list behind only Hugo
Cabret damn you Hugo just kidding I
really liked it look by the way this
smells really toxic plus it makes my
crazy eyes look crazier 2,300 librarians
just went on strike in Toronto what say
you I stand with the librarians unless
they don't want a guy with Sharpie face
standing with them in which case I will
quietly support them from a distance
favorite part about writing a book
having written was Hamlet mad no any
fishing boat proceeds this year alas I
am again fishing boat proceeds
lascivious babies are you working on a
new book
yet and I got to finish my stupid bad
zombie story first all-time favorite
Greek philosopher maybe obvious if
you've read the fall in their stars but
Z no what if Batman and sixteen sodium's
have in common no no no no no no no no
no what are your skills in drawing as
you can see my skills in drawing are
legendary
can you recommend any Swedish hip-hop
yes a faasil filthy are great although
best enjoyed if you don't speak Swedish
also snook who the eff is Hank Hank is a
cat running for the United States Senate
from the great state of Virginia hey
when are we gonna see your punishment
Hank while we were on tour you told me
that my punishment will strike at the
moment I least expected I've been living
in fear ever since but it still hasn't
happened so maybe he's forgotten why is
hazel called hazel because it's an
in-between code and she has an
in-between life in between health and
sickness in between adolescence and
adulthood in between swimming and
drowning etc what do you think the
difference is between a geek and a nerd
frankly I think the fact that both
self-identifying geeks and nerds are so
fascinated with this question indicates
that we might have quite a lot in common
with each other did you ever want to be
a teacher
yeah and now thanks the crash course
that kind of can be and not to geek out
or anything but I am totally living my
teacher dream i geeked out didn't I or
did I no doubt Hank my head is starting
to hurt from sharp inhalation so I'm
gonna let the crash course theme play us
out nerdfighters you haven't checked out
the show please do hank dftba thanks for
helping me get out of the friendzone as
if I was ever friend-zoned H is way off